thank you welcome everybody
the first question I usually have by
working with Gentile when I meet someone
I guess really doing software are you
kidding me
yes we do and actually I'm 15 years
doing numerical software at Intel and
Intel is quite good in doing this
software at least according to this EDC
developer surveys this libraries that we
do is among the most popular on the
market and why we are doing software
Intel is certainly hardware company but
by the time we launched the hardware we
want to make sure that the ecosystem is
ready for that
hardware and we are working with the
ecosystem in multiple ways we work with
big partners like Microsoft Google and
many many others to directly work on
their software to optimize the latest
hardware but we also want our software
our hardware and based on wide range of
software applications for that we do
software development tools so other
independent software vendors can use and
accelerate their software for Intel
processors so math kernal library and
integrated performance primitives these
are two examples how we deliver I
optimize it building blocks to the
market so market can reuse these
building blocks and run faster on Intel
processors so that's in a nutshell in in
reality it's really difficult to explain
people how big is the ecosystem of our
libraries and our tools and I had a
daughter she was four years old and this
is typical age when kids start asking
questions what I doing at your work papa
and I really had times to explain that
I'm doing math
it's really neat to touch something
physical when you do and mass is so
abstracted so fortunately Intel had nice
partnership with DreamWorks Animation's
in two thousand six seven eight and we
worked together with them to optimize
their software so they can create
brand-new effects really cool effects in
particular for this movie boots and
boots so when I was in theater with my
daughter she was so impressed by that
movie so when the movie is over lights
were on and people hidden to exit and my
daughter's still sitting in a chair and
she was looking at titles and there was
Interlaken title and she was amazed
Popeye I now know what you're doing at
int oh you're making cats that was very
easy way for me to explain now how our
libraries are used they really used
broadly for a variety of purposes and
because of that our libraries are also
our libraries and tools also part of
these student education courses at least
in Russia all major universities for
teaching programming for teaching
parallel programming they incorporate in
toad tools in their programming courses
so students are really become aware how
to get the best performance on Intel
processors by programming multicores by
programming for clusters etc okay to
give you a flavor what exactly this
software look like math kernal library
this is kind of library for
high-performance computing for really
compute intensive applications
it runs almost all ie based top 500
systems it's optimized for this
whole range of zum-zum fire and core
processor families it's C and Fortran AP
is it provides support for different OSS
unlike MK l the IPP library it's
targeting slightly different segments of
applications it's a signal image
processing computer vision and it
contains this building blocks optimized
for highest efficiency
unlike MK l which is heavy load
workloads this library deals with tiny
stuff so it's really optimized highly
tuned in assembly and we make sure that
overheads calling overheads to these
functions are really small so on the
left hand side you can see this is
really linear algebra FFT is random
number generator statistics vector math
partial differential equation solvers
here this is the primitives that you can
use for image processing computer vision
signal field ringing data compression
etc that's kind of libraries we deliver
to the market and I mean this C and
Fortran API is for these libraries but
really it's been used by broad ecosystem
of developers not only see important
developers and how we do that and our
engineers make sure that we publish
instructions how exactly to use these
libraries within Java within Python or
with dotnet languages with domain
specific languages like MATLAB or our
and other packages so it's really has
broad spread across the main domains and
languages ok I have some good news for
this particular audience
intel has free software program for many
years but this year we increased focus
on free software tools available for
researchers for students for teachers
for open source contributors so we
really have good news for you you can
visit software that intercom qualify for
free software and see what tools are
available to use for your work for free
in particular Intel still offers our
best software for money and the reason
for that many of our enterprise
customers they really value premier
support they really value the guaranteed
quality of support but we also fre have
three options for variety of audiences
like if your academic researcher working
on some project and you want to use any
of our library's math kernal library IPP
you want to use message passing
interface library or trading building
blocks you can get it for free if you
are student or teacher you are eligible
for cluster edition of our parallel
studio which beyond this libraries it
also includes compilers C C++ Fortran
compilers and performance analyzers and
tools for running these things in in
clusters also for free and again if open
source contributor you can get the
panels to you exceed professional for
free for Linux for your Linux work
that's one part of exciting news latter
parts of exciting news this is the first
one when Intel publicly unknowns
availability of new product which is
called Intel Dow data analytics
acceleration library which is now in
better
I was among architects of that library
and this is my baby
that's why I'm really excited to be here
and talk about this new product so what
it is this is a C++ and Java Scala
library for the
analytics you can imagine this is the
building blocks for machine learning
this is M key l like the difference from
MK l MK l focuses on the compute side
this library focuses on entire data flow
if you're a big data guy you really know
that bottlenecks are everywhere from
data acquisition data transformation to
data processing so we make sure that we
optimize all these data plots in stages
and also if you are Internet of Things
guy you imagine that then alex is now
run not only on your laptop or on your
server analytics runs everywhere on
every device so we make sure that our
library is optimized for all kinds of
devices Intel based devices and it
supports variety of usage models like
traditional analytics this is batch
analytics offline analytics but with big
data you really need to have
capabilities for distributed processing
of this data or you want to process this
data in blocks in real time when data
becomes available
so this library supports all these kind
of usage models online distributed
offline analytics that's important thing
this library is not tied to particular
platform if you had OOP guy this is fine
this library will run in Hadoop
environment if you're a smart guy
excellent this library will work with
spark and do distributed computing on
spark if you want to use this library
with NP NP I perfect this library will
work with MPI just be coffee because it
is abstracted from communication layer
if you are doing complex IOT analytics
you have multiple device multiple
protocols and all they communicate with
different protocols you really need to
have abstraction of these protocols this
libraries perfect choice for you ok
in terms of speed ups that we deliver
this library is based on this great
libraries that I already present mkl an
IPP be on the market for many years and
they are greatly optimized and by
reusing these optimizations we get
hundred tags better performance if we
run our for example or if you are using
Weka you can imagine 35 or better
performance on on select workloads this
is kind of optimizations that we target
a little bit more supported usage models
for data analysis that to measure usage
models if you are data scientist you
first start working in interactive
environment and it can be R it can be
python matlab excel whatever else so we
envision that doll can be really helpful
in these environments it can accelerate
your analytics on this traditional
desktop or laptop and where you run your
interactive environments and we know
many customers who are stuck with their
laptop they cannot run big enough
application on a laptop because of
performance issues or because of memory
limitations this library really opens
the door for extra opportunities on
interactive model inside and as a
problem is when your model is reading
you want to deploy this model in
production this library is also really
key in accelerating your analytics in
production and production I really mean
it's not only your data center your lab
with servers it's really across all
devices if your data is being generated
in on one end and being consumed on the
other end you really want optimize all
this floor this is where library in all
these pieces will run ok
a little bit more what kind of stage is
we target this is a typical data
processing stages data analysis stage
you start with data acquisition then you
do some data pretty processing like if
it's really big data you typically have
data compressed you want to decompress
this data sometimes it is encrypted
decrypt this data then you do some basic
filtering norma's ation if you have
really highly dimensional data you
typically want to apply some
factorization techniques or
dimensionality reductions like pca like
SVD so you can use this library to do
these transformations and then you want
analyze the structure of the data before
you apply a model you need to understand
how your data is organized so this
library provides variety of techniques
to understand your data like running
clustering algorithms running summary
statistics algorithms this is what you
probably want to do and then you want to
apply this data to train your model and
validate your model and then finally
apply this model for decision-making so
all these stages are covered by this
library and it's up to you as
application developer as a problem
solver to decide what part of analytics
you want to run on your edge device what
part of analytics you want to run on a
glide device and what part of Malick's
you run on the server
we have some good news for Python
development communities this year as I'm
finished with this dull project I am now
moving to the new project and my new
project is to bring this exciting
performance to Python development
community my new team is working on the
new technology that accelerates whiten
and what we do we we get python
interpreter we include some popular
Python packages like numpy Syfy pandas
etc and we integrate mkl and IPP with
this library so this libraries benefit
from our great optimizations in this
library and we all compile this with our
great Intel compiler package this so it
is really easy to install and out of the
box a usage that's a good news for you
is that we are working on prototyping
the performance analyzer for Python code
you probably know that existing Python
profilers they're really high overhead
and not very granular functional level
granularity or so Intel has great
technology which is called vtune
amplifier it runs with your C C++
Fortran Java code we now apply the same
technology so it can profile the Python
code and this is really exciting so we
are now delivering this as technical
preview package it will be announced
soon if you want to try this new
technology send us email scripting at
that intercom and will enroll you in
evolution we really need your feedback
on that so just to give you some initial
numbers this is not not a product this
is just the technology that we would
like the community to evaluate and
provide the feedback to us
our initial acceleration when we apply
em here for some linear algebra kernels
we see that you can get 6 times 10 times
15 times better performance then
traditional Python numpy package can do
you can deliver on multi-core systems
but even if you run a single core
application it will deliver you up to 6
times better performance and all this is
available for Windows and Linux now
later for for Mac OS and now it's both
2.7 and initially we deliver 3.5 for the
profiler so like I said most of existing
profilers like a C profile BF function
level profiling and also high
intrusiveness these technology is really
based on technique which is allowing us
to profile the line level with
significantly lower overhead and the
other heads at ten fifty percent which
is amazing compared to 2 X 5 X 10 X
overheads with existing fighting
technologies you can profile the entire
application without any code
modifications you just run the
application with within this Python
profiler and you get the profile ready
or you can run the window of your
application if you know that from second
five to second ten this is your
representative profile then you can you
can do that by using this technology
this is really nice GUI based and
well-known if you are existing vision
amplifier a user you'll find it you you
are ready to use it out of the box ok
these are our eating own dog food we
applied this profiler you know internal
infrastructure and we tuned python-based
scripts in variety of projects already
like one of our projects this is web
servers for billboard we were able to
reduce the time of running this script
from 90 to 28 seconds almost more than
3x improvement there's a piece of our
infrastructure around Python scripts for
key reports generation and that was
amazing
reduction from 300 seconds to less than
2 seconds that was amazing result of
using this profiler and also the build
system itself they've got some
bottlenecks that we we were able to
identify with this profiling tool and we
were able to reduce the build time from
6 to 3 minutes in our teams this is kind
of things that we think it will be
really available for Python community
that's why we asked you to participate
this in this technology preview and if
we see that feedback is really great
we'll probably continue doing more
exciting things in Python and other
scripting languages that's all I have
and I probably have some time for
questions
yep
so the question what is exactly in our
Python distribution technology preview
initially we get cpython
we get some other patterns like ipython
site on we pre built it for Windows and
Linux and we also get popular packages
about 40 packages including numpy pipe
anders matplotlib these kind of packages
everything is compiled test it we make
sure that it's good quality and easy
install it's it's kind of distribution
yeah and you can install other packages
with be provided in you know a package
yep the licensing this is technology
preview if we are talking about Python
and vision profiling so the license will
be evolution license evolution software
license yep it will be free for don't to
downloading test they are pre-built so
we're delivering binary package they're
part of this package mmm you don't need
separate license for all these like
I'm not sure I think that continuum has
some different technology at least we
did not test that I'm not sure it will
work
we'll make sure that it works with
people yes this is a nice feature the
libraries that around underneath like
mg/l and IPP what they do they do run
time CPU detection and they look I have
such amount of memory has such a big
cache size I have this instruction set
at in run time this libraries select the
best code path to run based on these
runtime information so by running this
yo this Python package it will link
MKL underneath and mkl itself will
decide the best number of course to use
to get the maximum performance yep and
if you don't want to use all the cores
there are some techniques to tune how-to
for fine-tuning all that information I'm
not sure that I hear you well
for math kernal library how much what
kind of controls do these libraries have
to tune performance I think that you
have some controls you can select the
number of maximum number of threads you
can select you can select whether you
want exact numerical reproducibility of
results like this is common problem at
runtime when you run on one core or you
run on 10 cores you may have slightly
different results because it will
schedule it and floating-point
operations I execute differently if you
want to make sure that exactly the same
results from run to run you have such a
controls to to tune this and that's it
okay any more questions
thank our speaker great thank you